And I want to welcome you all to today's special topic, which is about the alchemical process, or also on the transformation of personality. And it is a special topic because it's an incredibly hard and difficult topic. It's such a hard and difficult topic that I haven't touched it in 3 and a half years.
So I really tried to do an introduction already quite early in the Jung Helpdesk and the meetup group. But back then I really ignored the alchemical process itself, which is not easy, which is very hard to understand.
So now after more years of Jungian understanding, I went in there to say, okay, I want to make it now clearer because This is what the Helpdesk is for, making Jungian ideas more approachable. And I promise you, there's few things that are more in need of being approachable than alchemy and the alchemical process.
And what Jung says about it, what makes it interesting, is this alchemical process is also called the opus. That's a Latin word for work. And he says the alchemical procedure takes place within and without. So outside, inside the person and outside the person.
He who does not understand how to free the truth in his own soul from the fetters will never make a success of the physical opus. And he who knows how to make the stone can only do so on the basis of right doctrine, through which he himself is transformed, or which he creates through his own transformation.
Because Jung is a psychologist, And Jung is deeply, deeply interested in psychology and how human beings work inside. He looks at alchemy through a psychological lens. And there's a lot to it. Like, this is why he wrote really many thick books about the alchemical process and what it means and why it's important.
And this is something that's, let's say, when it's Jung the scholar, Jung the psychologist, Jung the psychoanalyst. This is very often ignored because it's like alchemy. There's people trying to make gold out of lead.
So it is a little bit of a hard topic to grasp, but Jung sees an incredibly value to understand how we function and also most importantly, how we change and develop, because this is really what Jung interested the most. He was a psychotherapist.
Meaning he helped people to transform themselves back into a functioning state in their life. They had a problem, they could not live their life normally anymore, and he would help them through the process to get to the other side. So it is about transformation and he sees there strong parallels to the alchemical process.
And to give a rough overview about Jung's life to understand like what the value for him was and the importance of alchemy. He really invested a huge part of his life and a huge effort to go deeply into this topic. This is not only why it's a thick stack of books, but he really, really thought this through deeply. But let's start at the beginning.
Carl Gustav Jung was born in Switzerland in 1875.
In a small village and he went to school, went to university, got his medical degree in Basel around 1900, where he started to work in a mental institution, the Burghölzli, and started to do psychological research into, um, yeah, the people that they had there.
And the people there were people with Schizophrenia, with psychosis. So really strong medical conditions, and he would try to understand them and would do like tests and like cognitive experiments to see what is really happening there. Especially when you have people that are completely catatonic, meaning they're completely shut out from the outside world.
What is happening there inside of them? What are they experiencing?
Through this research and through his work and his scientific work that he did there, he met Freud, and this is a very well-known friendship, a friendship that did not last forever because there were certain differences in views about psychology, especially as Jung saw a larger picture where he also saw a place for religion, uh, spirituality, the occult, and, uh, mythology and all these different things that Freud rather tried to reduce of importance and saying like, oh, this is a mother complex.
Oh, this is a father complex. But Jung saw there really a huge value in understanding human beings.
So this led up to, to a breakup in 1913, which was also around the time when Jung started to get visions, meaning he had experiences about Europe drowning in blood, which happened before the First World War and basically got also confirmed through the First World War, which put him at ease because he said, okay, I'm not crazy.
He thought it's very ironic. The, the, the doctor gets crazy just as the patients that he treats. But this was a basis for The Red Book. And most stuff we know about Jung, like the collective unconscious, anima, animus, shadow, all these different things, self, this really started with those visions and The Red Book. And he worked on that in secret.
Nobody really learned about it. It only got published like 15, 15 years ago or something like that now. But it was a very close-kept secret to his closest students and his friends and his family. But this changed, this changed this endeavor on exploring his own dreams, his own visions, and his own psychology and trying to make sense of it when he received a book.
And this book was The Secret of the Golden Flower. It was an alchemical treatise translated from Chinese the first time in a European language into, into German. And a friend asked him whether he could write, Jung could write the foreword for that.
And he read that book and it absolutely blew his mind because it absolutely paralleled the experiences and thoughts he had during The Red Book. This was kind of the confirmation that what he did there was not an individual experience of himself and he's just writing down his, how his own psyche works, but he discovered something fundamental.
And he had some outside sources who was already thousands of years old, confirming and coming to similar conclusions as him. So this is really when he started to investigate alchemy deeply, very, very deeply, and where he would not stop talking about it up to his death in 1961, also in Switzerland, in Küsnacht.
So we can really separate Jung's life out in 3 blocks, and most people know this middle block, the collective unconscious block with anima, animus, shadow, self, and so on, but not so much known as the psychoanalytic part, which is also very good, very interesting, and very strong. And what is, let's say, also known but very hard to understand is the alchemy part.
And what Jung would do there not only write books about it, but he was actually furthering this discipline. He would collect and buy alchemical treatises that were hundreds of thousands of years old and let it be translated into German.
So for example, one of his students, Marie-Louise von Franz, only got hired by him because she could translate, uh, ancient Greek. And he had those texts and he could not translate them because he could only do Latin. So he would hire her so that she would translate then those texts.
So he would translate them and be then the first to really bring them into modern European language and then also trying to analyze them. So he would write a dictionary of the symbols, trying to understand these very, very, very difficult treatises. I'm showing here the books that he's written on that.
It's like Psychology and Alchemy, which was the first English book being published by Jung in the US. It's Alchemical Studies. It's Mysterium Coniunctionis, where he himself says this is his magnum opus. This is the culmination of his thought and ideas. And he wrote that very late, like end of his seventies, he published that.
Then Aion, very famous book, was supposed to be a chapter in Mysterium Coniunctionis, but it got so big that he said, okay, this is now its own book. And as a little bit of surprise, the book, The Practice of Psychotherapy, has a lot of alchemy in it because you just have it when you have late stage Jung. He always finds a way to talk about alchemy.
He connects everything to alchemy. So what is alchemy? Alchemy is a science. It's a, it's a material science.
It's looking into the world and the idea that there is a spirit trapped in physical matter and that this spirit can be released through human beings, through the right work, through the right process, and can lead to a transformation, a transformation that creates something valuable out of something invaluable. So this out of lead, gold is created.
Lead, very base, normal, everywhere you can find it, into gold, which is very rare and very valuable. The alchemical idea is the gold is already in the lead, but it needs to be freed. There's a spirit of gold in the lead. So human beings, for whatever reason, have been doing this already for thousands of years.
So we have alchemical texts from different cultures in China, in Greece, in Egypt that write about this process. And the weird thing is there were never alchemical schools. There was never a kind of alchemical training.
It was just that people all by themselves started to investigate the physical material world and started to play around with acids, with metals. They would start burning things, distill things, all these different things. Like alchemy is the basis of chemistry. It's actually a term that comes from Arabic.
Al means the, it's like, uh, The, chemie, similar as algebra, the gebra, and so on, which is a fun fact to know. So you had all these people that all by themselves got this idea to work on this, to practice alchemy, and then to write this down.
And they had their own symbolic language that was very individual, but also overlapping. So this And that was what Jung did. He took all these different texts from all over the world and tried to find similarities, and he would find those similarities. And that during a time where there was not really communication or exchange between those people.
So he said, ah, this has to come from a deep part, from a universal part of the psyche, from a collective part. This is not only the individual person as an alchemist, but something deep inside of them wants to manifest itself. And that we have the same thing with culture and with art and with mythology and so on.
And the Western type of alchemy happened to kind of parallel to the Catholic Church. So Catholic Church, huge institution for the last 2,000 years. And you have that, but also very spiritual endeavor with, uh, you have the father in heaven and we have life at earth, which is kind of sinful.
And when we're good on earth, we get into heaven into a way of perfection and have their eternal life. While, so it's a kind of disregard for the earthly, the fleshly, the material, and so on. While alchemy is the exact opposite. It's saying, oh, we look at the material because there's something there. It's unfinished and it's actually creating something.
It already assumes something godly, of godly powers to create something out of, let's say, nothing. So alchemists had a very hard time. They had to work in hiding.
Like, for example, there was a pretty big alchemist enclave in Prague a couple of hundred years ago, and they were hiding in the Jewish district and had to work very much in secret because they were also persecuted for being alchemists.
And, but you already have this counterbalance between the spiritual Christian religion and this then very materialistic alchemical pursuit. So Jung already sees that's a kind of compensation, it's a kind of balance taking place.
And what is absolutely true is that alchemy, as its point of trying to investigate the material world to gain knowledge from it and to transform it, is the basis of science, how we practice it today. And a lot of famous Scientists were alchemists. Sometimes that was even their main job. Newton's main job was an alchemist.
That he invented modern physics was kind of happening on the side. Uh, actually he would try to win a bet by, there was the motion of some, uh, moons on Venus needed to be explained. And yeah, this is how he came up with modern physics. But we also have Boyle, uh, we have Paracelsus. Who founded modern medicine.
We have Kepler, who was very much working on astrology, and we have Leibniz for mathematics. So we, we have these people and this idea of saying, okay, if you investigate something and if you have the right procedure, you can do something with the world. And for us, this is now completely normal.
We say, yeah, we can transform the world and we can transform material to create something new out of that. But this started with alchemy. This was started with kind of outsiders working in the shadow and in the dark and following their intuition, let's say.
And what Jung saw there, what was driving them was of course their psyche, but their elaborations, Jung said they were kind of naive about their own psyche, saying what they wrote down and what they formulated, of course, was an investigation of the material world.
But he said at the very large part, and this is the staple of Jungian psychology, they projected their own psyche into the outside world. He said this is normal phenomena that we have when we are unconscious about things in us. We perceive them at, at the outside. We think that's the outside world. This is objectively true.
So what he's saying is When the alchemists melted metal over the fire, peculiar vapors arose, and then the colors of the rainbow appeared on the surface of the metal, which they called the Cauda Pavonis, or peacock's tail, because of all the colors.
As they were so deeply concentrated on their work, expecting the great miracle to happen, they began to see visions in the vapors that arose. There they saw not the miracle that was in the matter, but the miracle that was inside themselves. Because the interesting thing is alchemy has incredibly strong, incredibly hard to understand symbolism.
So this was what will this event also be about, to get familiar with the symbolism, but also to understand it, what it means psychologically. So the alchemists being naive about their own psyche, seeing it on the outside writing then down what they think they see outside, like, oh, the, the green lion appears, or the peacock's tail. And this is at this stage of the process.
Says they're actually communicating how their psychology works. And because they don't see it as their own psychology, they're then very, very honest about that. This is what Jung was incredibly interested in, and this is why he was interested in schizophrenics and dreams and hallucinations. In the occult and into mythology, spirituality, and so on.
Because it says these are all, they're coming out of the psyche. They are formed by the psyche. And when people are not aware that they're talking about their psyche, they tell the most amazing truths because they don't have a filter. So what is the goal of alchemy? So why are the alchemists doing these things?
Why are they sitting in a hole for a long time, uh, looking at metals and burning stuff? And Jung, summarized it as this: our gold is not the common gold, non aurum vulgi, not the gold of the vulgar. Only ignorant people think we are seeking the metal, the material gold.
What we are really seeking is our own gold, the most precious substance, the sun substance. And this is the alchemist gold, not the physical gold, but it's an idea and it has many, many different names. It's called anima in the sense of soul. It's called the quinta essentia.
It's called the aqua permanens, the tincture, the lapis philosophorum, the sorcerer's stone, the philosopher's stone, the elixir vitae, the panacea, the diamond body, the golden flower, just like in the book that Jung received, or the unus mundus. And the idea really is there. You have something.
And it might seem worthless and it might seem wrong and corrupted, but you can transform it in something beautiful. And the example that I have here is coal. Coal is just carbon at its core. You have these brown lumps of something that are very brittle and can break easily, and they're very flammable, and they can burn easily, and all these different things.
But just by rearranging the atoms of carbon, You get a diamond, which you cannot burn, which is clear, which is very strong. And it's the same atoms, but they're rearranged into a structure, into some higher order unity, from chaos to unity. And he says, this is what the alchemical process is about.
It's the transformation from something that is chaos into order, into something more, something better, something higher. And he says, this is not only what happens in the outside world, this is what's happened inside. And what is the kind of prerequisite? He says, this elixir of life, the alchemist cannot find unless they transformed themselves to be able to recognize it.
So it is not something that happens outside of the alchemist. The alchemist themself is participant in the process of transforming lead into gold. Carbon into diamond to create something really eternal. And the alchemical process follows 4 stages, 4 phases. The first one is nigredo, which is called the blackening.
The second one, the albedo, the whitening. The third one, the rubedo, the reddening. And the fourth one, and the final stage, is the citrinitas. The yellowing. And for those who are familiar with the podcast might recognize those colors because that's the logo of the podcast. It's really the colors of the alchemical process from black to white to red to yellow.
And this is the kind of order that he found through the alchemical texts where people agreed on. Not, let's say, 100%, because even in the field of alchemy, stuff can happen over thousands of years.
For example, the last two stages, the rubedo and the citrinitas, sometimes they're switched, that the yellowing becomes for the reddening, or they're combined, and then only the reddening is the last stage. So I stick to this because this is what Jung talked about the most.
But he says like, oh yeah, there was some brand new innovation during the 16th century that they left out the last stage and the process started with the reddening. But he saw there a kind of also influence through the Catholic Church, that it was more closely aligned to the, let's say, Trinity.
So, so what does it mean to have the blackening, the whitening, the reddening, and the yellowing? The very first stage, the nigredo, is also called prima materia, the first matter.
Carl Gustav Jung describes it as It is a pure black substance, which the old alchemists called nigredo, that is blackness, and understood as night, chaos, evil, and the essence of corruption. Yet the prima materia of gold, sun, and eternal incorruptibility is inside.
So it is that you have this black mass that is unseeming, that is incomplete, that is kind of useless. But in it is the spirit is trapped, the spirit of perfection, and that only if it's transformed, it would be that. It's the same kind of way, but it's in the beginning.
So he says, the philosopher's work begins with melancholia and ends in pleasure and joy. This initial state, the nigredo and the tenebrositas, are also called melancholia. It is a state of depression. So the imagery that is used there is very often then the night, darkness, blackness. Similar also how Jung sees it for the unconscious.
The unconscious is a dark place and a frightful, scary place because we don't know what's going on there. Something appears out of nowhere and it's very frightful. It's not clear where something begins and where something ends. It's similar when you encounter, for example, a problem in your life. Like you might not even know yet what the problem is.
You don't know where it starts, where it ends, and how to solve it. So this is why it's perceived as chaos and something that is seemingly endless, formless, untouchable, unreachable, uninteractable with. This is where everything starts. This is the lead. This is the coal. This is the blackening. So it moves then on to the albedo. The whitening.
And this is where he says, ah, the first light appears out of darkness. The first light appears. And he says it's a very white light. And the alchemists talked about it as moonlight or the sun when it's just about to come out. So you, in darkness and blackness, there comes the opposite. There comes white as a kind of counterpoint, as something pure.
You have the very impure blackness and the very pure whiteness. And this suddenly starts to emerge. And this is when the heavy symbolism starts. So we will dive here right into an alchemical text with an explanation of Jung and how it works psychologically.
He says, the dragon devouring itself is a form of libido, which runs in a circle within itself and bites into itself. The dragon forms a circle with itself bites into nothing but itself and even fertilizes itself in doing so. Experience shows that the libido, when it comes out of the state of depression, bites into whatever is there at the moment.
What then occurs is called transference. The libido does not necessarily bite into itself. That is why the alchemist says that the lion or the dragon had to be kept in a sealed vessel. Otherwise, the locked-up content, and thus the whole alchemical opus would blow up. The lion has to devour itself. It is stewed in its own juice.
For the greatest desire, the greatest pleasure does not seek the other but itself. So already heavy, heavy symbolism in there. To explain, libido for Jung is psychological energy. That means when we do something, when something comes up, it's charged with libido.
Meaning if you have a thought or idea comes up, you have a kind of threshold that separates consciousness and unconscious. And the question is, why does something suddenly come out of the unconscious? Because Jung says, ah, it's very rich with life energy, with libido. And also when you start to concentrate on something, you invest libido in it. It becomes like clearer to you.
It becomes more salient, more detailed. So you're investing something in there. It's like concentration. This is also how we could understand it. And what he's saying, and this darkness where really nothing happens, suddenly things start to appear. They come out and they're charged with energy.
And he said, what's happening there is because it comes from no energy to some energy, it's very aggressive. He says he's noticed that with his patients when they had a neuroticism, like, uh, they had problems, uh, depression, which was very low energy, meaning the libido was trapped in their unconscious.
When it finally came out into consciousness again, that they became very often very egoistic. They're very driven, but then also very singular focus to single things.
So he saw that also happening with Nietzsche, and he says it's then very important to keep this together that people not start using this energy, new endeavors, new relationships, all these different things, because it actually has to stay with itself. It has to kind of devour itself like an animal devoured itself, like this image of the ouroboros, the snake that eats itself.
This is what this is about. So you have the black mass, there's things coming to start coming out and they have to be separated out. There has to be order created out of the chaos.
And the best image that I can give you is when you have watercolors and you play around with them, especially as a child, like the first idea is to gather all the watercolors and put them into a single liquid and they become brown. You have a lot of colors and they turn into brown.
And if you would this adding of different colors, put that in reverse, you would suddenly pull out of the brown yellow. You would pull out red, you would put out blue and all these different things out of this brown mass where seemingly nothing is in. You get these colors that are inside, but they're trapped.
So this is the same thing that psychologically needs to happen, that the parts of the psyche have to be made salient, aware, and separated out from the other things. For example, when people We would call it jumping to conclusions, that people become very obsessed with certain ideas. They move very, very quickly.
Like, oh, they feel bad. They feel a sensation in their body and they say like, oh, this is cancer. Oh, this is, ah, I was poisoned. And they say like, oh yeah, this is because my boss does not like me. Or like my partner tries to kill me or whatever.
It's this connection of different thoughts and ideas that get clumped together, and suddenly the person is very emotionally charged. They're taken by their unconscious on a ride, on an emotional ride. So the libido is in them, but it's not consciously available, but it rather takes over the wheel and drives them to be obsessed with certain topics, certain ideas.
They're not then free. They're very trapped by that. And Jung says it needs to be separated out. The different thoughts and the different ideas have to be separated out. And their own individual things. And this is a kind of circular motion that's happening there. It, it has to be then really charged with energy and it has to be really contemplated. What does it mean?
What is this? What is that? How do you feel? What do you think? What could it mean? And this is already part of the analytic process. So this is why it's called opus circulatorium. And out of that comes the rubedo.
So it's going from, you have your confused mass, you have your separated out parts, which takes a long time to separate out. And he says those have to be now reconfigured in a higher order because he said what human beings really like to do is to be one-sided. They pick then one thing and say, ah, This is the way I want to do it.
He says, when people like thinking, they do everything with thinking. And he said, then you become very one-sided. And this is why the previous stage was like white. It's ideal. It's perfect. But at the same time, it's sterile and incomplete. You need there more. You need life in it. And this is what the rubedo, the reddening, the coniunctio is about.
That you then start bringing these different parts again together. But in a different configuration as before. It was chaos before, but you create now order. So he's saying, in order to make it alive, it must have blood. It must have the, what the alchemists call the rubedo, the redness of life.
Only the total experience of being can transform this ideal state of the albedo into fully human mode of existence. And symbolically, The white-skinned lady lovingly joined to her ruby-limbed husband, wrapped in each other's arms in the bliss of the connubial union, merge and dissolve as they come to the goal of perfection.
They that were two are made one, as though they are one body. So the magnum opus that are shown of Jung, the Mysterium Coniunctionis, the mystery of the conjunction. Of bringing things together, of the unification. This is what this is about. Because you have then all these things and their opposites. He says thinking and feeling are opposites.
Introversion, extroversion are opposites. Masculine and feminine are opposites. Eros and Logos are opposites. They fight and contradict with each other, but they have to be brought together and into unity where they both serve their function and play together. And this is what's happening here.
So it's The white-skinned lady, so the albedo moonlight needs to be brought together with the rubedo husband, with the masculine. And this is what's happening with the coniunctio. And when this happens, you reach the citrinitas, the lapis. This is then the Philosopher's Stone.
And Jung says, it is a symbol of the opus alchemicum, since it breaks down the original chaotic unity into the four elements and then combines them again in a higher unity. Unity is represented by a circle and the four elements by a square. The production of one from four is a result of a process of distillation and sublimation, which takes the so-called circular form.
The distillate is subjected to sundry distillations. So this is then really, when you reach this yellow phase, you reach this perfection phase of the Philosopher's Stone, of the sun substance, of the alchemist's gold.
And the way to there is very confused and complex because what you end up with is almost the same as what you started out in the beginning. And he says, this is a mistake that Many people do, not only the alchemists, but they do not yet recognize what is of importance because they cannot perceive it yet. They have not changed that.
They need to change themselves, which changes their perception of the world because the world as we experience it is a reflection of our own psyche. That he says, this is very often disregarded. This is a typical story in alchemy.
He says, The matter of which the stone is made, or in which the precious stone is found, is what is trodden underfoot or thrown onto dung heaps, cast out on the road. So what is found in the end is actually what was already there in the beginning, but was completely disregarded because people don't understand yet what it means.
And this, I think, is a typical realization when you have a hard problem and you think about it a very long time. You already have the feeling, ah, I got this in the beginning. Like for example, Albert Einstein, his equation of relativity, he already had that very, very early in his career when he was still working at the patent office.
But it took him 8, 9 years to really understand it, to really prove that it's true and then publish it. And that he says it's a very typical thing that people already have the right idea, the right feeling, the right intuition, but they do not understand it yet.
They need to do the whole process of psychological transformation and therapy and individuation, all these different things to go like, oh yeah, that's right. I have a very good example, which is very often the advice that you get from parents.
I have to say, I get a lot of advice from my parents and there's a lot of stuff they only understood decades later where I thought, oh yeah, oh yeah, that's right. That's exactly how it is. But I did not believe it. I did not understand it, but now I do. So certain things just need time and psychological Transformation.
And Jung says this is what is described in the alchemical process. So what I want to go into now is the symbol of the alchemical process, because I think now it's made very clear how it works. This, you have darkness, you have the very dim light of the moon or the sun about to rise.
Then you have the rising sun, which gets stronger and stronger, and then the kind of peak sun that's on top, which is light is consciousness, dark is unconscious. You're moving from an unconscious to a conscious absolute conscious state. So Jung sees there, or the alchemists see there, very strong symbols associated with that. So for example, with the nigredo, it's earth.
With albedo, it's water. With rubedo, it's fire. With citrinitas, it's air. Those four elements that we know from a lot of pop culture, they come from the alchemists. They come from Heraclitus and also other alchemist. So those are very contradicting elements. Water and fire are contradicting. Air and earth.
God created the earth and everything by separating out the sky and the earth. To bring this then together and reach their unity, this is the alchemical process. Having seemingly contradictory things coming together. And this transition that's happened there, this moving from darkness to bright, is symbolized, for example, also in animals.
And he says those stages are associated in visions and dreams, in alchemical texts with animals. And he says, ah, the nigredo, it's black, it's earth. So what lives in the earth? It's snakes, it's toads, it's dragons. Well, in the West it's dragons. So when this starts to transform, It goes into warm-blooded animals. It goes into lions.
It goes into dogs. Those then transform into winged animals. So same as the sun rises, the animal starts from below the earth, in the earth, to on the earth, and then above the earth. And those are then eagles or a peacock. And he says the final thing, it is a resurrected man. It is the anthropos. It is was also called the second Adam.
Similar how God created the first Adam out of clay and air, you can see there also unification there. He said it's human beings creating the second Adam out of matter and this to create health, wisdom, and health and all these different things.
So, and we reached it through science in a degree. Like we, we lived out now the alchemist's dream. Now we live longer, we are healthier, we have more possibilities, we fly through the sky. And we did this by releasing the spirit that is trapped in matter. Our world is running now on semiconductors.
Semiconductors are quartz, they're sand, and we are transforming sand into speaking stones. That it makes it possible for us to talk now from different sides on the earth and to watch videos and produce things and all these different things. This is because we freed then this spirit that was trapped in the matter.
And this is also then in this line of animals when it's only birds, like a raven. Why a raven? Because a raven is black for nigredo. A swan. Why a swan? Because it's kind of on the water. It's between kind of earth and air on the water. So, and it's white. And the peacock, why the peacock? Because it has these many, many, many different colors being displayed.
So that it is coming together of these many different things, but they're already starting to come together. And then for citrinitas, the final stage, the phoenix. Why the phoenix? Because the phoenix is constantly dying and being reborn. It burns itself out, it goes into blackness, into darkness, and then is born of that again.
Similar as a resurrected man, similar as the second Adam. So Jung saw there within his endeavors into the alchemical texts, these symbols coming up and again and again. So it means when you are encountering now an alchemical text, this will already help you to understand that better.
And this cognitive function that Jung talked about, he associates then also with those stages, like sensation very being aware of things. It's about earth because it's very down to earth. And says people who are strong in sensation are down to earth people. They believe what they see, right? They're not up in the air, but they're down to earth.
And the albedo, the ideal phase, he said, oh, this is thinking people. Thinking people have a very abstract, removed existence from the world. They think about stuff. And it's also like, say, up in the Air, it's, um, then very fluid. Yes. And they're thinking, but at the same time, also a little bit lifeless and dead because it's too abstract.
It's too ideal. And feeling with fire. I think we don't need to talk about that. When you have strong emotions, when you really have a strong feeling for something or against something, for someone or against someone, that this is associated with, with fire and the color red. Love we symbolize by the color red and white we have for the lab coats, the thinking part.
And yeah, intuition, yeah, the things that might be possible and how they change and transform over time. Similar as the phoenix change and changes and transforms over time. And he would even associate that with different directions that we have for west, north, south, and east. And this we also find in the symbolic texts.
So when you see there, when they talk about the West, and we, we have this, the West is the place where the sun goes down. So the symbolism makes sense there. We are living in the, in the Abendland, in the Occident. And in the East, it's the, the Orient. This is a rising sun. This is where the sun is high. So this is where the, the intuition is.
And it is a little bit more in the air. We even have that for the dragon. In the West, it's in the ground, and in the East, it's up in the air. And he says, yeah, the North is also always seen from a European standpoint, of course. The North is cold, same as the intellect is cold. And the South, it's warm, same as feeling and emotions are warm.
So if you can get, time behind that of this symbolic thinking, like how does it feel? How are you perceiving it? Having a little bit of a naive way of how to interpret things and having then these associations and coming together.
You can see here in the columns that in themselves, they make sense to connect the west to the earth and to the night and to a raven and to sensation and corporeal animals and all these different things. So This is what makes it also incredibly hard to understand the alchemical texts because they're laden with symbolism.
And what I wanted to do here is to explain to you the process and also the symbols associated with them, because then the texts really become way, way, way, way easier. And I had a very hard and long time to understand all of this. This is why I haven't touched it for 3.5 years. I talked about it 3.5 years ago. And haven't touched it since then.
Because yeah, you, you have to think in a very, very different way. And I recommend touching alchemy only when you have a strong Jungian understanding. So what I can promise you here, that what you're getting here is a kind of introduction into alchemy that you can do nowhere else, because only possible with a very, very, very strong understanding of Jungian ideas.
And like, one of the biggest ideas of Jung, and the one that's he already started before he received The Secret of the Golden Flower was on individuation. And now a lot of things click and make even more sense. Because individuation means to become an individual, an inseparable whole, something complete, something where the parts are integrated.
He says when we are born, how we are, our interest, our personality, everything that we could be is already dormant in our unconscious, in the darkness, in the chaos.
And it's our task to get this out, out of the unconscious through a process of separating, combining, of distilling, of burning to reach their higher form of unity, to make things make sense. And this is what happens when people are in a melancholic state, an oppressive state. They don't understand why this happens.
They don't understand where they're in, how they should behave. Everything seems unsure and untrue, and they become more sure in their development, and they understand, and they can connect, and it's like, oh yeah, that just means this. Oh, this is what this means.
And they start to separate out the wheat from the chaff, the good from the bad, not throwing away the bad, but transforming the things. The things that might seem like bad can be transformed into very positive things.
And a lot of successful people, In life are successful because they took the dark sides, the shadow side of their personality and transformed them in their biggest asset.
Like the, the UFC fighter Conor McGregor, he became one of the best of the best because he said he wants to be aware of everything that makes him afraid and he wants to modulate it. He wants to act this out. He wants to become the things that he is afraid of.
And other people, who's the guy who runs a marathon a day? David Goggins. He was fat and said, oh, he doesn't want to be fat anymore. He was very unsporty. He said he will not last long. He will not have a healthy life. So he went into the exact opposite to transform himself into a sport machine. And now he inspires other people.
So it is this idea to go into the dark and the unpleasant where the dragon is, because there the treasure hides. This is Jungian psychology through and through. And I think now it's clearer why he became so interested in alchemy, because it mirrors there like, oh, there's a dragon that devours itself, but it needs to eat itself out so that the gold can come out of that.
And where the beauty then comes out. And that the psyche unfolds here like the lotus over time through the process of individuation, through attention and care and patience. So this is what he says. He says, the help which alchemy affords us in understanding the symbols of the individuation process is, in my opinion, of the utmost importance.
And this is why he would not shut up about alchemy, because it confirms his ideas about individuation that he already had doing his work on The Red Book, where he was in his lowest point, where he lost his friendship with Freud, where he basically lost his career, where he would have his visions and thought he's going crazy. And he transformed that into a career.
He transformed that into universal knowledge by pursuing this, the dark, scary parts that nobody pays attention to. He looked into the occult. He looked into spiritual. In the mythology, and this is what broke the friendship with Freud, to looking in the dark places, because he says there is value there, and there is a process and a method to get to this.
So he says, becoming conscious of an unconscious content amounts to its integration in the conscious psyche and is therefore a coniunctio Solis et Lunae, of the sun and the moon, of the masculine and the feminine.
The process of integration is one of the most important helpful factors in modern psychotherapy, which is preeminently concerned with the psychology of the unconscious. Combining conscious and unconscious, getting things out of the unconscious and making them usable for the person. That's the purpose of psychotherapy, of psychology.
And he also said of living, we already do that to a certain degree normally, but we need help. We need help from other people when we can't do it ourselves. When we are really lost in depression, and melancholia, and we see only chaos, and we do not see the golden there. This is what Jung talks about really a lot.
The value and the seemingly valueless and the senseless thought, the senseless ideas. He said everything that you do and experience is connected to you so it can teach you something about you and can help you to unfold your personality, unfold your psychology to become what you, like, ultimately were meant to be.
And this is what he saw in the alchemical process, and this is why he was so interested in that. So to summarize what it was about today is alchemy is a projected psychology, and the process of alchemy mirrors the development of the psyche. And this development is really the separating, this combining, and doing that again and again to really think things through.
And it's, it's pretty clear, and I think it's clear to everyone. When you have a problem and you are unsure, you can talk endlessly about it. And when other people have problems, they can also talk endlessly about it because they're trying to figure something out.
It's like a drive and also already an intuition that by bringing it to light, to inspecting it, by separating, by combining, by investigating, that you're transforming your thoughts and your ideas and your behaviors, and that also transform yourself into something different. Up to the point where it's like, oh yeah, actually this is not bothering me anymore.
The horrible thing that happened to me, the horrible thing that always bothered me. And this is also what he saw in his patients, that suddenly the things that were super important and grabbed them and had them like an animal chase them down in their dreams disappeared because it became part of them. It was not separated anymore. It was in them, but at the right place.
So here's a quote from The Red Book. Where he says, this thing for which you have sought so long and is not to be acquired or accomplished by force or passion is to be won only by patience and humility and by determined and most perfect love. Because it is a long and difficult process.
And I think everyone who went through difficult psychological problems and depression and other hurtful thoughts know that this is a very, very long process, but there is light at the end and there is a kind of method to it. And the important thing is to know that it's something universal, that people are never really alone.
So I would want to thank you for your attention, and I really hope you learned something, and I really hope it became clearer about the alchemical process and the symbols and so on, that would be awesome. That would make me really, really happy because it's very difficult. It's incredibly hard.
It's very, very difficult to get good ideas, good content, and understanding for that. And this is always my goal to make it really the best it can be. And if you're interested to have kind of follow-up episodes that, or events that will talk about very closely aligned topics. I talked about alchemy and active imagination.
It's episode 9 of the podcast. I talked about individuation. It was episode 15. And I talked about the cognitive functions very, very deeply when I talked about the inferior function. And there it's also about this going into the dark and finding the value there. This is a very strong theme in Jungian psychology.
So I would want to thank you for your time and attention, and I hope you had fun.